ten days after fleeing their home with
their six children
Robina and allie her son have returned
to see what's left of it Robina says
they fled when they saw groups of men
setting houses on fire and the most
stuff a bad neighborhood Quintilian what
it was nothing of ours is saved we just
took our children and ran for our lives
the family is one of at least 1,700 that
have been displaced in Northeast Delhi I
don't know how my children will continue
their studies everything we have worked
for is destroyed I just want all of this
to be over and to start a new life
Robina and her family have been staying
with relatives others are taking shelter
at this nearby relief camp that's been
set up by student and civil society
groups around five hundred people are
staying here everyone has a story
including these cousins Alfia and
upsetter when we were running away they
were throwing stones and that's when I
got hurt they burnt many shops we were
watching from the roof of the house they
even burnt our mosque the olia mustered
in the neighborhood of Shiva hide is one
of at least four mosques that were
destroyed the violence began on February
23rd when fighting started between
Hindus and Muslims protesting against
the citizenship law that critics say
discriminates against Muslims what that
led to violence from both communities a
fact-finding team says Muslims suffered
disproportionately all of them how left
that place but it is Muslim whether it
is Muslim community or the Hindu
community but when you look at the house
as the building the Ender houses of the
Muslim community is damaged no damage to
the Hindu houses Delhi police have
arrested 1600 people but the families of
those killed or injured say they want
politicians to be held to account
a few hours before the violence started
on February 23rd Kapil Mishra a member
of the ruling bat at the Ajanta party
said his supporters would take matters
into their own hands unless those
protesting against the citizenship law
cleared the streets Mishra didn't
respond to Al Jazeera's request for an
interview the Delhi government has given
compensation to those affected by the
violence but many who've lost their
loved ones their homes or their
livelihoods because of their religion
say it will take more than money for
them to feel safe again Elizabeth
puranam al Jazeera Mustapha bardelli